a lot of very interesting calls today at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's oh this is
interesting
let's go to ferris from saudi arabia
you're calling from saudi arabia right
now
yes i am nice to meet you dave likewise
and are you
are you saudi or are you uh someone
working or living there
no i'm originally from saudi uh i'm
living here in called the city
um yes i am is the david pakman show
big in saudi arabia
to be honest i'm not 100 sure yeah
because i've been watching some news
about what happened this
uh covert 19 oh the case is like
over 15 million my god i'm very
shocked yes yes indeed
well what can i do for you today yeah
um i have a question about donald trump
um
i don't when i see the on the news um
something about uh operation warp suite
yes it all all this election all this in
a
it's all it's a complete mess now he's
making a self
full of it i don't know how the
um sorry my cat wasn't me yeah i can
hear your your cat seems very very
aggressive
he's always like this um
just one second please sure sure
listen i may even have more questions
for you but yeah
yeah go on so uh how do you feel about
um opening up women driving is that
something you like
hmm not really but i was kind of
surprised that women finally can drive
uh in the aura but
that's the good news but so hold on a
second you said you don't like it but it
is good news
no no no no i'm i didn't say i don't
like it any
uh i'm not i don't know the question to
be honest
no no i'm just asking are you in favor
of women
getting the the ability to the legal
ability to drive in saudi arabia
yeah i i think they have a
ability to drive no i understand
of course they have the physical ability
just like anybody else but are you
politically speaking do you do you like
that are you in favor of it
in favor of
do you support women driving in saudi
arabia
yeah i support it you do sorry about
that that's great
because my sister i have a sister to be
honest because she needs to drive
as well right as a practical matter you
support it
yes yeah all right first listen um
this is all very very interesting i'm
gonna let you go because we do have a
lot of people waiting but a very
interesting phone call um and
we had a cat and we had a number number
of different things going on there